[Applause]
[Music]
wait
you can't say that anymore fifa
announced that it won't accept improper
behavior from the fans
and consider this a homophobic call but
how did it start believe it or not
this has its foundation in american
football
yes in monterrey during the 80s
according to the american youth football
association
they used to say
boom at the moment of the kickoff this
expanded to soccer
on may 1st 1999 thanks to the atlas fans
club inside
jalisco stadium where the first victim
was the ex-goalkeeper of the mexican
national team
oswaldo sanchez according to him
but this chant soon became popular
during international competitions
and it was not until the 2014 world cup
in brazil
when fifa decided to put a stop to this
long
time tradition
since then fifa said that the national
team could face several punishments
including a fine not allowing funds
inside the stadium
taking points away or even suspending
the team from an international
competition
from 2015 until now the mexican soccer
federation
received a total of 14 fines directly
from fifa
we talked to former goalkeeper of the
mexican national team adolfo rios
and this is what he says
[Music]
and the mexican soccer federation came
together
to motivate the fans to stop yelling
this chant
inside the stadiums
[Applause]
during the national league's final the
game was
interrupted as a first warning following
the protocol of a discriminatory chance
mexico will now play at the next edition
of the gold cup
meanwhile players want to remind their
fans to enjoy the game
without offending the rival reporter for
a news now
natalie lancelotti